don't say anything offensive and be on
your best behavior
um joke about how we shouldn't talk
about politics because I know how you
can get look about how I should just run
because I'm not ready for this I'm not
ready for this appearing normal trying
to hide the pain of knowing you've slept
with my daughter snap judgment based on
the handshake stereotyping you based on
your wardrobe in your hairstyle inviting
words
I have never tried to mind my manners
this much my entire life
pressing something that Kelsey put on
Facebook that makes me realize how much
I know about you embarrassment no and I
clearly I'm so supportive of it
extrapolating on that because it shows
some very I don't care can I get some
information about your background I
would like to know about your family
about your child I need to find out
whether you match up oh that reminds me
of something you have to do with your
car aggravated short response oh and I'm
reminded of a bill I paid of yours oh
boy I'll say anything that comes into my
head feeling like I'm in high school
again avoiding any form of internal
conflict in order to summarize positive
things about my upbringing specific
details in order to make my middle-class
family feel as affluent as I assume
yours is that phrase reminds me of
something oh my god that Kelsey did when
she was little I was so so so impressed
by her acting on emotions that I haven't
felt since I lived here directing it
towards you first impressions are so
important I just don't want to be
negative reverting back to my high
school self I don't need you in the
kitchen abandoning you uh-huh
are you the type of person who likes
talking about themselves no I have the
water to a tryst but my goal here is to
find out what I'm desperately trying to
connect to um on those interests
pretending to believe your attempt and
now calling your bluff Oh actually
surprising myself by how well I'm
currently backtracking so you like the
same things I do definitely lying I
planned this whole dinner out
meticulously and now I'm stressed out
because it didn't work out according to
plan
changing the subject to what chores you
want me to do because I'm continuing the
contemptuous relationship so ease out
without that pain and I'm trying to stop
that I just I want to remind you about
how much fun we have I love you it's
just a genuine question because I'm
worried about your well-being to bore
you with slides of one of my best
moments because well you're basically
forced to watch over emphasizing how
interesting this is Oh claiming a story
is mine even though it actually happened
to a friend
feeding small phrases well naughty
Oh and showing you uh that hiding that
I'm having computer problems because of
pride oh you're making a very simple
mistake that anyone from my generation
could help you with excuse about other
people using the computer and messing
with my stuff actually a very very
simple thing that everyone knows
presented like it's an insider secret
step checking that my other snap
judgments were wrong
taking a breath becoming an adult again
look I I can't hide that I'm unsure
about your dreams and you look a little
fatter mama I'm so sorry oh there I go
again don't be around because the way we
communicate is symptomatic of a much
larger issue I approve of your choices
but I value security pretending I don't
want attention right now
um I'm passively siding with your mom
because I'm them liking me as much more
important than whatever you're arguing
about I'm finally feeling needed
understanding why I am being ganged up
on right now and willing to go along
with the plan I am impressed with how
you handled the situation and you can
begin to let your guard down slowly over
the course of the next five years